[Music]
things don't go smoothly when you're
around people like this they shake
things up
so you need to ask yourself what is it
that you want from your society are you
happy being are things good enough is
the status quo satisfactory enough that
you can all
sit back and privilege
agreeableness and say let's just all
abide by the rules of civility and
everything will be fine or do you think
actually
there's much to be gained
um as a society if we if we do
change up the status quo and introduce
an element of
of um
of friction into the way uh we all
behave
what can we do as a society that allows
people to express
their disagreeableness are there ways in
which we can make
dissents
deviation
disagreements just more
palatable more easier to do
in the workplace what do we think of as
the role of a manager
is the role of a manager to
tolerate dissent or find a safe place
for descent or to
um obliterate dissent a lot of managers
actually try very very hard to
obliterate dissent and think that that's
how they ought to be measured the
success ought to be measured whereas
this would suggest actually no maybe
what we want from managers is
the people who ought to be managers
ought to be the people who have the
thickest skins
um
the ones who are just more who are the
most comfortable with some degree of
friction in those who are under there
um under their control and i think
that's about
how do you structure education so that
children
are taught that it's okay sometimes to
be
rebellious or questioning or skeptical
um
or that our willingness to tolerate
disruptive
behavior
in people of our own kind
is far greater than our willingness to
tolerate in um minorities in those who
are powerless
and so what that leads to is
not just higher levels of
punitive action towards
people in disadvantaged groups but also
disadvantaged groups themselves changing
their behavior to meet those different
norms so you see among
for example in this country
african-american parents who privilege
good behavior
in their own children as the most
um as the kind of um
uh
primary endpoint of childhood
whereas you see parents
who are in the majority
who will privilege achievement
good performance
as the primary endpoint you only
privileged performance over behavior
if you're in the group that is allowed
to behave in unusual disruptive
disagreeable ways and
i think that is an unacknowledged
source of a great deal of
of of um
inequity
in in modern life that we just
have these different standards for
people on the inside and people on the
outside
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video